this week in our world of motion series
we've traveled on roads rails and across
the sea to show how and why people move
today we take to the sky to see how
flying has the power to change lives
Charlie d'Agata went to Dundee Scotland
where Britain's Royal Air Force is
helping some remarkable teenagers get a
new outlook on life
for most flying as a matter of function
a means of getting from point A to point
B that many consider tedious or even
ordinary but as these young boys show
that all depends on your point of view
take 13 year old Cameron herring he'll
be the first to admit he's around 1,000
feet outside his comfort zone did you
ever think he'd fly a plane
no what do your friends think of this
they think I'm bonkers they pick your
punkers yeah why because patrasche
bonkers because Cameron is flying blind
literally high above the hills of Dundee
Scotland just like you just feel the
aircraft I just hold it like okay
he lost his vision three years ago and
now manages the world around him from
memories of his ten year old self are
you envisioning what you're seeing kinda
and what do you see
[Laughter]
I guess I ask a stupid question that's
it I get a mystery illness left him in a
coma and for a time unable to walk for
that he says he's lucky things could be
worse
and what does this mean to you Allah
because when I was in the hospital the
doctor says I've been a wheelchair all
my life
it's just really good to be doing this
stuff
Cameron and his vision impaired friends
are taking part in a program run by the
Royal Air Force there we go
really at the heart of it what we're
trying to do is use flying as a medium
to help young people achieve their
potential and that's irrespective of
their background whether they've got
physical disabilities or perhaps social
you know they're socially deprived area
so about that time to lift them up and
help instill a belief and if they can
soar above the clouds maybe they could
do anything certainly help Daryl Stewart
we want to see in the plane nice and
confident nice and relaxed yeah
more relaxed and I was as we got to
experience Darrell's first landing what
was the best part about it probably the
lot that was good
the Royal National Institute for the
blinds Jane Coates says it helps young
people see the world differently when
they get to try something this exciting
the smile on the face says it all for me
they come out and the buzzin and they're
so proud of themselves you can see that
the spirits been lifted
Cameron was a gifted young athlete when
he lost his sight something he's not
going to give up on now like I do judo
boxing running the drums I do other
stuff that's what I love to do and I'm
not going to stop it because I'm going
I'm not going to stop things like this
we have a phrase and the air force about
the sky's the limit but actually for the
people today we want this just to be the
beginning and that's how we want to use
it so this guy isn't the limit in though
not anymore for CBS this morning Charlie
d'Agata Dundee Scotland